you
hi everyone is Gerry let's have a look
at a game between Ignat Sivan Popeil
playing on the white end and Jorge Marco
this was played at the Monte Carlo
tournament in 1902 this tournament
consisted of 20 of the world's best
players to name a few others that were
competing Harry Nelson Pillsbury sigvart
Arash Karl Schlichter Mikhail Trigorin
Frank Marshall the list goes on many of
those names I just shared probably ring
a bell they were pioneers to the opening
variations we know today so let's dive
into this one and see what made it so
special
let's see in what position mr. Marco
committed his ultimate blunder von
Popeil opening up with E for Marco
replying with e 5 we have a Philidor
defense what's the great excitement with
this defense if there's one square that
should stick out it is a 5
white will look to overtake this point
black will be there to secure it with
the Queen Knight and the Queen as we
will see
Queen there night there why is this such
a big focal point well if a five is no
longer that would mean the e4 pawn would
become mobile and at any point can of
course push and maybe the knight his
post would be brought into question it
could have this type of domino effect so
continuing we have Knight to g5
pinpointing f7 this is conveniently
defended black makes a move that he
wanted to play anyhow and defends f7 now
and we know that it's just not a good
idea to give up to minors for a rook and
pawn so what is really the point of
Knight g5 it was a clearance f4 is now
available putting pressure on e5 black
expands on the Queen side
Bishop needs to find a new home and now
a six so this solidifies b5 so a black
is aiming for now c5 striking at the
center
castle's Bishop b7 rook a to e1 and at
this point 12 moves in both sides are
connected with their rooks how will play
follow up first the Knights given a kick
and this is where Marco now goes hunting
for the Bishop and at this stage white
says you know what my Knights going to
probably get kicked he's going to have
to find a new home and well I'm okay
with giving up the bishop he retreats
and is prepared to promote the knight
next on III c5
bishop just yet instead follows through
with this idea after a six c5 was the
point
so the bishops eyes are open d4 is hot
c3 follows and now we have some of the
tension released he takes d4 C takes d4
Knight takes bishop now that the
position has opened up you know things
are looking nice for the bishops and now
we have a capture on e5 Knight takes and
improving the knight this square is
finally available he five you could play
this move but well you'd be losing a
pawn now it is mobile but there's enough
support on it still
Ian soon there's going to be a bishop
there as well and even a rook c5 is
difficult to play so there's an isolated
pawn pawn duo here let's see how play
develops first it's Knight to f5 this is
a super invasive Knight you know the
bishop is not around to combat or help
fight for the f5 square and he's a
difficult piece to chase away g6 is
dropping upon so you kinda have to work
around him let's see how black does this
first it's Bishop f6 this is the
unopposed
Bishop and it's hard to argue with
placing a bishop on the longest dog and
on the board an unopposed bishop placing
it on the longest diagonal usually a
good idea
six is a good post Bishop is out of the
Knights way now and we have rook F to e8
so something to note about this position
these two bishops are not competing for
the same diagonal you know whose
diagonal is better is a question you
know at any point let's not forget that
h6 has been played g6 is a little bit
soft and white could look to play e5 and
form some kind of a battery sneaking
into the King side this is a possibility
at some point this kind of this
clearance move just pushing e5 opening
the bishops eyes and preparing a battery
first its Queen f3 just getting out of
the rooks way but you know at the same
time it's opposite the bishop you know
but there is this idea to to play d5
taking advantage of the pin pon playing
playing defy right now why could reply
with E 5
so queen is better on f3 than e2 these
nights are strong black is looking to
challenge one of them and is successful
with these next handful of moves we have
a night capture and after the pawn
recapture it closes the rooks eyes along
the e-file but it addresses this strong
post on f5 he has to find a new home
White says not just yet I'm gonna pin
your pawn black on pins so now he has to
find a new home and decides on e3
continuing we have a check King h1 and
the offer of a queen exchange wiped as
well to decline it making the best move
here Queen to d1 and yeah there's this
idea now to slip into g4 h5 and this
light Square you know now that black has
captured like this g6 is a you know that
should really stand out in one's mind
this is a weak point in blacks camp and
the bishop is ready to eye it up so
black has to be very careful here this
next move is not good by team black
black goes pawn hunting capturing on b2
a better choice is to make sure this
diagonal never opens black should play
e5 here white is still 4 choice in this
position but yeah II 5 is the best move
here shutting the diagonal for good
Bishop takes b2 in the game
white does not follow up in the best way
'if I've would be best ensuring the
diagonal is opened and then trying to
form some battery looking for made on h7
instead like O's in scoops up upon
Glee saying you took my polymer to take
yours but now the Queen you know there's
a downside with capturing this
particular pond because now the Queen is
is going to get struck out you know the
rook is now activated Queen has to do
you know a move where she just she's not
connected with any other white piece
she's just all by herself over here on
the Queen side and okay she's throwing a
punch but she basically just has to
relocate and does next Queen f2 Bishop
d4 Queen f3 and what to do now it's
queen is constantly getting harassed one
way or the other
rook f8 the bishop on b7 she's in
multiple pins so what does white do
first is rook c1 Queen B for Queen d3
seems a little bit awkward but the
bishop can't go you know I can't make a
move there's a an unprotected rook on d7
b v now
was this idea to play e5 and then go for
me so ii v it is f take c5 rook takes
rook rook takes rook Queen to e7
that's a game losing move a big shift in
the evaluation after Queen to e7 a
better move here is rook to d8 and at
least you have the option to move the
bishop and be protecting your rook you
don't have that situation now dark
square Bishop rook that's on a light
square not not possible in this
situation rook d8 it is possible so in
the game we had Queen d7 not the better
move rook to d8 and what follows is
Knight to f5 e 6 would have been even
better with the idea to finally push
through with E 5 and open this strong
battery up Knight f5 is also winning
Queen takes e5 is the follow-up and pop
quiz to you the viewer
it's way to move
would you play here as white feel free
to pause the video
okay in the game the move that was
played is rook to d1
a better move in this position would be
Knight to h4
looking to not only take advantage of
this pin but also simply land a deadly
four again let's not forget about that
weak point on g6
so night h4 was best but in the game we
had rook to d1 and one more pop quiz
black to move in this position what did
Marco do next feel free to pause the
video
okay in the game Marco resigned
that was his ultimate blunder
say it's an ultimate blunder because
black is actually winning
what is the winning move that Marco
missed in this position feel free to
pause the video to figure it out
okay the winning move here well first
before I show the winning move
what made Marco resigned most likely
it's this pin bishop
apparently cannot move it's hit three
times it's only defended twice and you
can't defend it again and it seems like
you can't move the bishop but indeed you
can with the bishop and should move the
bishop to g1
that's the star move that Marco missed
he resigned again in this position in
this winning position instead of this
star move Bishop g1 attacking the Queen
saying go ahead take my rook because I
will then take your king but he missed
it he made an ultimate
blunder do you have any first-hand
experience with an ultimate chess
blunder I think I might have done that a
time or two in only a bullet game but
certainly not some serious over the
board game like this tournament game
this Monte Carlo tournament of 1902
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
and also yeah if you suggested RIPTA d
how many of you thought rook to d1 was
the best move for white that's actually
the losing move but marco resigned
instead of spotting Bishop to g1 how
many of you thought it was rook to d1
how many of you came up with that one
anyhow feel free to leave any feedback
and I hope you enjoyed this video that's
all for now
take care
you